[Música]
la belleza es un tema medular en todos
nosotros
en cómo nos vemos a nosotras mismas y
como vemos el mundo
cuando hablo de belleza me refiero a
belleza en todas sus expresiones desde
el plano energético desde la belleza en
nuestros pensamientos en nuestras
emociones en nuestras palabras y como
eso se traduce en belleza en la forma en
la vitalidad de nuestro cuerpo en la
belleza de los espacios todos en esta
vida experimentamos manifestaciones
bellas y desagradables
algunas veces nuestra energía está
vibrando alto y nos sentimos inspiradas
y capaces y felices y algunas otras
veces las energías trabaja y nos podemos
sentir tristes estas motivadas inseguras
entender porque oscilamos de un lugar a
otro nos da dos facultad el conocimiento
para escoger en qué lugar queremos estar
en el transcurso de mi vida trabajar por
mi estabilidad emocional ha sido un
trabajo de tiempo completo en el cual me
comprometí cuando tenía 21 años después
de la crisis más grande que tuve en mi
vida
en ese momento busque amor cuido
compañía y conexión en lugares y en
personas equivocadas
esto terminó en una crisis en una
sobredosis y tres semanas en el hospital
completamente fuera de mi centro podrían
imaginarse lo devastada que me sentía en
ese momento lo insegura lo fea lo
indefensa
sin embargo fue ahí cuando empecé a
caminar y a conocer la verdadera belleza
qué es belleza qué tipo de belleza
tiene la belleza una relación con
nuestro instinto biológico tiene una
base científica o responde solamente a
condicionamientos sociales
qué papel juega nuestra percepción
nuestras emociones nuestro estado
energético espiritual para poder
percibir belleza incluso para crearla
estas fueron preguntas claves en mi
proceso de sanación
donde explorer y leí los primeros
pensadores y teorizador es que hablaron
sobre la belleza y ahí encontramos
aristóteles aristóteles hablaba de una
belleza en la forma él reconoció que la
belleza tiene que ver con una proporción
matemática simétrica que se representa
en diferentes patrones de la naturaleza
en plantas en hojas en flores en la
proporción de nuestra cara en la
proporción de nuestro cuerpo y que a su
vez tiene un propósito mayor la vida la
existencia
luego leí sobre platón y platón ya
hablaba de una belleza con unas capas
más profundas más sutiles en la semejaba
la belleza a la bondad la belleza a la
sabiduría
einstein lo dijo en su propio lenguaje y
de una forma aún más sutil
es la energía el que comanda la
partícula es decir la materia
entonces si nos ponemos a pensar que
cada pensamiento que tenemos es una
corriente eléctrica que si el repetitivo
va a crear un comando individual y que
eso va a afectar al colectivo
tocamos una verdad muy profunda donde
reconocemos que el fondo y la forma es
solamente una eso para mí fue sanador
porque pude conciliar conceptos que en
mí se sentían completamente antagónicos
como la belleza y la inteligencia la
superficie y la profundidad
fue ahí donde tuvo un renacer donde
salió una nueva versión de mí y donde
tuve la capacidad de crear mi proyecto
de moda etérea y ahí visión es una marca
que no solamente tuviera productos
lindos para vestir sino que también
comunicaron mensajes más sutiles
un tipo de vida un estilo de vida
consciente responsable amoroso con el
medio ambiente con la sociedad
estando en la industria de la moda me
reconocí descubrí que estaba una de las
industrias más atroces que existe en
este planeta
la moda es la segunda industria que más
contamina el planeta después de la
industria del petróleo en china se dice
que se sabe cuál es el color de la
próxima temporada por el color de los
ríos
a nivel social
la moda maneja muchísima trata humana
salarios de un dólar al día todavía
existe en el 2018
la esclavitud moderna está escondida en
nuestros closets
y a nivel psicológico todos sabemos el
poder de influenza que tiene la moda y
los medios y qué causa en la mayoría de
los casos depresión y ansiedad por lo
que tengo no tengo por lo que soy o no
soy estándares de belleza que solamente
responden a intereses de unos pocos
esta es una realidad muy triste sin
embargo existe un movimiento ya un
movimiento de moda consciente
donde hay diseñadores como un un
auténtico interés de cambiar ese
paradigma y ofrecer productos hermosos a
nivel estético pero que también tengan
un propósito
ya cada vez tenemos más productos en el
mercado amigables con el medio ambiente
como son las telas hechas de plástico
reciclado sacado del mar productos que
cuentan una historia de mujeres
valientes jefas de hogar que están
trabajando fuerte para mantener a su
familia y que ahora gracias a esta nueva
industria consciente tiene la capacidad
de tener un empleo decente donde pueden
desarrollarse profesionalmente y
personalmente
productos estéticos innovadores pero que
no invitan ser desechados en la quinta
puesta
esto no sería posible sin todos nosotros
consumidores conscientes que ya estamos
demandando un nuevo paradigma en la moda
que queremos productos que comuniquen
otra cosa que respeten el medio ambiente
que cuiden a la humanidad
ya no queremos mensajes que nos digan
cómo tenemos que lucir
es ahora cuando estamos creando una
nueva moda una nueva tendencia que viene
para quedarse donde la creatividad y la
innovación empieza en nuestros adentros
donde estamos generando nuevos hábitos
de consumo amorosos solidarios y
responsables donde estamos siendo
capaces de materializar de manifestar
desde el plano más sutil una belleza
holística
donde estamos siendo capaces de vibrar y
de volar alto y juntas
y donde como hoy seguiremos celebrando
vestidas de nuestros derechos valores y
esperanzas
gracias
[Aplausos]